some people have said i'm overly
sensitive
[Applause]
[Music]
what now
and by some people i mean everyone
while i may not be x-men material i have
always possessed unusually heightened
senses you
georgie put your shoes back on
you can't smell this yes i can
i also had extraordinary hearing
during dinner i could tune out the
cacophony of chewing
slurping
chewing
cutlery scraping against plates
and my father's heavy breathing as he
wrestled with a ketchup bone
but tonight there was one sound i
couldn't tune out
why aren't you eating sheldon
how can i with that horrible noise
what noise that irritating high-pitched
buzz
i don't hear nothing me neither how can
you not
wait
i think i hear it
you do
yeah it's coming out of your face
i guess i hear a little hum
free traders make noise yep this is new
it's never made this sound before we
should call a repairman i'm not spending
money on a fridge that's working then
think of it as spending money on my
mental stability ignore it sheldon
ignoring things that irritate me isn't
my strong suit
obsessively fixating on them now that's
what gets me out of bed in the morning
[Music]
what are you doing
the sound from the refrigerator it's
right between d and d sharp ugh it's
making my skin crawl
what if i hold a pillow of your face for
like a really long time no that's
dangerous
do you know if we have earplugs if we
did i'd be wearing them go to sleep
i can't
put your fingers in your ears and risk
driving wax back into my inner ear canal
no thank you
oh
[Music]
good morning
are you trying to kill me
no i think you're great
then why are you in my bed i couldn't
sleep our refrigerator is making a weird
noise
but so was one of your nostrils so don't
expect me back tonight go home before i
call the police you wouldn't call the
police on your moon pie then i'll call
your mother
that you would do
and leave my extra key behind
[Music]
my